[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the minneapolis police chief takes the
stand in the derrick chauvin trial
the chief's opinion on chauvin's use of
force the day george floyd died
that should be condoned hear from the
emergency room doctor who tried to save
floyd's life
he was in cardiac arrest plus will
chauvin take the stand
in his own defense we ask a local
minneapolis defense attorney
yeah you might as well and our
investigation continues into the man
seen in the car with george floyd on the
day he died
maurice hall appearing in court for his
own hearing and charges he faces
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to long crime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
who's in minneapolis right now and with
us as always is terry austin
week two of testimony is underway in the
derek chauvin trial but before witnesses
were brought in
there was a potential issue with the
jury brian what went down
before testimony was heard the judge in
a very wise move
i might add put a package on on each one
of the jurors desk
ask them to flip to the first page and
see if they recognize that social media
post
then ask them to flip again and see if
they recognize that person
now you and i and anyone else is not
going to know what's seen there because
the judge is actually going to destroy
all copies but one
and keep that in the file the judge said
that based on the judge or the jury
sorry's
reaction to those questions he found
them to be credible and there was no
issue of outside influence from any kind
of media jesse
all right thanks brian appreciate the
report now one of the most highly
anticipated pieces of testimony
was from the minneapolis police chief
now if you remember the chief
fired chauvin the day after floyd's
death calling it a murder
and condemning chauvin's actions now in
front of the jury the prosecutor asked
the chief if he believed
chauvin followed his de-escalation
training
i absolutely do not agree with that and
how so um
that action um
is not de-escalation and
when we talk about the framework of our
sanctity of life and when we talk about
the principles
and values that we have that that action
goes contrary to what we're taught
i must ask you is this a trained
minneapolis police department
defensive tactics technique it is not
the conscious neck restraint by policy
mentions light to moderate pressure
when i look at exhibit 17 and when i
look at the facial
expression of of mr floyd that does not
appear
in any way shape or form that that is
like to moderate pressure
i absolutely agree that violates our
policy
the prosecutor next asked the chief if
he believed chauvin use of
use of force was reasonable
there's there's an initial
reasonableness in trying to just get him
under control over the in the first few
seconds
but but once there was no longer any
resistance
and clearly when mr floyd was no longer
responsive and even motionless
to continue to apply
that level of force
to a person proned out
handcuffed behind their back um
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that
is by policy is not part of our training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values
on cross the defense asked if the
growing size of the crowd could have
affected chauvin's actions
as a crowd grows or becomes more upset
part of it is to try to de-escalate
which can involve
trying to avoid a physical constant
confrontation
right yes trying to stay safe
concealed and covered right yes not
yelling back at somebody not engaging in
them
with them verbally right yes
and sometimes when an officer
tries to de-escalate a situation and
someone is so
upset right sometimes they don't hear
what the officer tells them
would you agree with that objection
speculation that calls for speculation
it is sustained
okay let's break it down terry the chief
of police was extremely well trained and
obviously very familiar
with police policies and procedures but
what parts of his testimony do you think
will be most impactful with the jury
listen i think chief arredondo was one
of the best witnesses i've
ever seen jesse i mean obviously he was
qualified he's been on the force since
he was promoted every two years and
actually i think the jury is going to be
impressed with his background usually we
don't listen to that
but here i think it was very important
and from a substantive standpoint
obviously the fact that he was able to
say chovin's use of force
was not objectionably reasonable and he
did not
follow the de-escalation policy so
i think those two issues and also
this was important the fact that he
didn't follow the code of ethics he
didn't treat people with
dignity and respect the jury is going to
hold on to
all of those things especially since
it's from chief arredondo
who the community respects very much and
i think it was
very impressive well he was definitely a
witness that we were waiting for and
brian
we were also waiting to see the cross so
were were there missed opportunities by
nelson do you think there were things
that worked well what did you think of
the cross
so overall nelson is attempting to as we
usually say
poke holes but the way in which he's
doing it he's trying to create
generalities as to how police procedures
occur
to try to see if he can slide his way in
between those cracks
the prosecution seems to be filling up
those cracks as quickly as possible
but i think he's he's working as best as
he can he doesn't have a lot of facts in
this case
that helps him so he'll bring it to the
general concepts
and then the prosecution will bring it
to specific using those facts
and those figures and that information
that actually occurred
i don't know how powerful it's going to
be but i do think he's gaining some
arguments
that he can make consummation brian
there's a lot to break down with what's
happening in that courtroom and clearly
there are supporters for george floyd
but there's not so much for derek shovin
right i mean his family
is not there in the courtroom
exactly in the past we've seen that the
individual who was sitting in the seat
that would be
for derek chovin's family is a court
officer
now that's because no one has come for
derrick chauvin's family as yet
it actually removed that seat not for
any other purpose
other than that when someone does come
for derek chovin or if they do
they'll put it back there for that
family to be represented but that isn't
the case as yet
wow i don't know if a lot of people are
surprised at that but here's what i can
tell you still ahead on lawn crime daily
will the man seen in the car with george
floyd on the day he died
take the witness stand but first we
asked local experts will chauvin
take the stand our legal analysis into
the case of the former minneapolis
police officer on trial
next
[Music]
welcome back everybody one of the
biggest questions in the derek chauvin
trial
is whether the defendant will take the
stand long crimes kim johnson spoke to a
local attorney who thinks
he just might kim hi jesse yeah all
eyes are on minneapolis during this
trial but court observers
are paying specific attention to how the
defense and the prosecution
lays out their case now so far only the
state's
witnesses have been called to testify
they include several minneapolis police
officers describing their training on
use force last week the head of mpd's
homicide unit called derrick chauvin's
use of force
quote totally unnecessary and adding to
that minneapolis police chief madera
arendando testified that he thought the
use of force
was also unjustified and that a person
accused of a
counterfeit bill would not be taken to
jail meaning george floyd
shouldn't have been arrested well-known
minneapolis criminal defense attorney
joe tamborino
says using these witnesses and testimony
as experts
is damaging to the defense
i'm sure at this point the chief is
going to say that mr shelvin used
excessive force
or at least that he violated policy and
this is the problem
with having anyone you want give their
opinion
it's going to confuse the jury think of
it right now there's body worn camera
from the three co-defendants whose trial
isn't coming up till august
but all of their words are now in this
case it's as if they're testifying
against mr chauvin but mr chauvin can't
cross-examine them
now that all that's in now that all
these people have testified
there's nothing to lose yeah testify of
course
now the judge will likely ask chauvin if
he will take this stand after the
prosecution arrest escape
case that is likely a a discussion right
now between
chauvin and defense attorney eric nelson
jesse all right thanks kim now here's
the question terry
do you think chauvin will actually take
the stand and if not
why not listen i think it would be
extremely risky if in fact nelson put
joven on the stand he may go on
but i think he's going to come across
very negatively to the jury
you know right now his personality is
cold and calculated and i say that
because
we see him sitting at the defense desk
we can see that he is just sitting there
taking notes he doesn't seem to be
disturbed by anything
we've seen him in the bystander video
where he's just sitting there
holding floyd's neck down with his knee
and we also know from various reports
that other officers said he wasn't
really
very personable so i don't think he's
going to come across well but i also
don't think from a substantive
standpoint
he's going to be able to add much
information because
there's no way he can justify the use of
force
when he is asked on cross-examination
why did you not
take your knee off of george floyd's
neck he's not going to be able to answer
that question when the prosecution asks
him why didn't you de-escalate the
situation
he's not going to be able to answer that
question so
not only is he not going to come over
well as far as the jury is concerned
from his personality but he's not going
to be able to substantively answer
any of the questions i think it would be
very dangerous to put him on the stand
all right well it'll be pretty
incredible to see what actually happens
if he does take the stand because we all
want to know what was going on in his
mind
and why did he feel it was necessary to
use that restraint
coming up on law and crime daily the
doctor who declared george floyd dead in
the hospital
testifies and why derek chovin was there
too
[Music]
george floyd was officially pronounced
deceased after he was brought into the
hospital
the emergency room doctor says floyd was
in cardiac arrest and considered
possible causes such as a drug overdose
but says it's more likely his heart
stopped because of
oxygen deficiency that was
one of the more likely possibilities i
felt that
at the time based on the information i
had it was
more likely than the other possibilities
and doctor is there another name for
death by oxygen deficiency asphyxia
and you did not uh in the course of your
consideration uh
provide naloxone or narcan no
okay and if you do have opiates in your
system the administration of narcan
uh could be life-changing
life-saving yes not in this case
there is an answer you wanted to clarify
uh please do so only to state that
narcan administering narcan to someone
who
potentially suffered a fentanyl overdose
once that individual is in cardiac
arrest
the administration of narcan would
provide no benefit
all right terry so you're hearing dr
langenfeld discussing the use of narcan
for a possible overdose do you think his
testimony helped
or hurt the defense actually jesse at
the end of the day i think it hurt the
defense at first when i heard nelson
asking dr langenfeld about the narcam i
was a little bit concerned because
narcan was not given by any of the emt
personnel or the police officers and
the testimony was it could have saved
his life if it was
in an overdose situation and that it
wouldn't have
hurt him and it was a safe procedure but
then
you heard the prosecution get back up
and say
listen you wanted to clarify what was
your clarification
and the clarification was if you give
narcan to someone
who is already overdosed and is in
a cardiac arrest it's not going to help
so
i think that that was cleared up and i
think at the end of the day
point for the prosecution brian there
was an interesting back and forth with
the cross of the doctor and then the
redirect by the state
are you getting an insight into maybe a
strategy of the lawyers here
yeah so it's interesting after the
weekend i think both sides kind of
reevaluated what they were doing
and observe what the other side um had
put forward for the
defense they're sticking with their plan
of trying to broaden this
as much as they can to poke holes in it
much easier
now you're hearing the prosecution
basically saying all right i get that's
a possibility like the narra cannon
situation
but talk about these facts and these
situations but i think the defense like
terry is saying is making a mistake
because
the prosecution can come back and say
yeah narcan could have been used
if they took his if derek chovan took
his knee off george floyd's neck
and gave it to him before he passed out
that probably could have saved his life
and that line of thought could be very
detrimental for the defense
uh brian 20 seconds here's my question
you had such a strong witness for the
prosecution who can the defense call
that kind of competes with the doctor
here
you got to bring in your own doctor
you've got to bring in someone who knows
about overdoses who wasn't in the er who
maybe
wasn't rushed to find a conclusion and
maybe make that argument but er doctors
are some of the best and brightest
uh they work under under the gun so to
speak
i think it'd be hard to combat that
testimony yeah i mean when he said
basically these possible causes
for cardiac arrest and really narrowed
it down to
oxygen deficiency or deprivation that
was a
big moment for the prosecution you know
who heard it the jury
when we come back george floyd's friend
maurice hall is in court
but for his own case find out when to
expect a c
hall in judge cahill's courtroom
the man who was in george floyd's suv
the knight police approach
appeared in court for his own case long
crimes anjanet levy is here to tell us
what happened
and other legal troubles for marie's
hall that he could face
and jeannette jesse george floyd's
girlfriend testified that she
and floyd would often buy drugs from
maurice hall and one defense attorney in
minneapolis believes that could be just
one of the reasons
that hall does not want to testify in
derek shovin's trial
courtney ross testified tearfully about
how she and george floyd became addicted
to opioids
both boy and i are our story it's
it's a classic story of
how many people get addicted to opioids
we both
suffered from chronic pain mine was
in my neck and his was in his back ross
testified that floyd often bought drugs
from maurice hall
and that she took floyd to the hospital
two months before he died
because he had overdosed he spent five
days there
now maurice hall says he will invoke his
fifth amendment privilege if called to
testify
normally when someone says i'm not
testifying
you get the prosecutor to give you
immunity you see because the prosecutor
could force mr hall to testify all they
have to do is say we're giving you full
immunity
which means he can't be prosecuted for
any crimes he can't be violated on his
probation nothing but so far they
haven't done that
so why not minneapolis defense attorney
joe tamborino says maurice hall
could be asked to answer questions that
could lead to him being charged with
third degree murder
in floyd's death third degree murder has
two parts
one is what mr shelvin is accused of
which is a depraved mind
extremely dangerous act the second part
to third degree murder is giving
someone drugs and that person dies from
the drugs
so yes you're right um if mr hall
doesn't testify
it helps the prosecution
now the judge in that case in maurice
hall's current cases actually i should
say
refused to reduce his bail and the woman
he was ordered to stay away from that he
was
accused of assaulting or convicted of
assaulting she was actually in court
by a zoom to show support for him now
maurice hall had an arrest warrant out
for his arrest for a case in another
county that involved sex
trafficking and solicitation his lawyer
said in court
that he wasn't aware that he was needed
in court for that that the information
went to the wrong address
and the um hall is actually going to
appear in judge cahill's court
on tuesday morning and there will be a
hearing on this
issue about whether or not he will be
able to plead the fifth
in the chauvin trial jesse pretty
interesting and jeanette now brian
what do you think the lawyer for hall is
thinking right now in terms of his
client testifying
yeah he's thinking my client's not
testifying uh unless there's going to be
some sort of
magical plea deal where he gets off on
the charges that he's being charged now
or there's as the local attorney said
some sort of absolute immunity
otherwise if i'm his defense attorney
he's not making it a hundred feet from
this building
because i don't want any of his
statements to be heard by anyone
and jeanette when will marie's hall be
back in court on those felony cases
actually it's going to be in june and
when
maurice hall's public defender she asked
for that june court date or at least a
couple of months the judge said
why would you want me to push this out
so far i'm not reducing his bail
and she said that she's working and
hoping that she can get some type of
omnibus
or kind of complete overall um
overreaching
resolution to all of these cases and she
talked about having to talk to one of
the prosecutors about that so
she wants to work something out kind of
like a big deal that includes also that
case in the other county involving the
solicitation
along with those other cases in hennepin
county
so pretty interesting that she's um
eager to wrap all of these up into one
and get some type of deal worked out
right and terry you got to think
what the value is for him to testify for
the prosecution i mean do you think
maurice hall should be given immunity to
testify
in the derek chauvin trial absolutely
not i don't think he should be granted
immunity at all
that should only be granted when there's
critical information
that a witness can provide for a trial
so for instance
if a witness needs to testify against
another defendant to
secure a conviction or if you need to
find the body of someone who's been a
victim in a crime then you might give
immunity to a witness
but here we don't have anything like
that his testimony
is not needed we already know and we've
already established
what the crowd what the bystanders
witnessed he was a bystander
we don't need that information and we
already know
from the girlfriend from courtney ross
that
there was an opioid addiction so he has
no value to add as far as i'm concerned
and we should not
at this point give him immunity i don't
know i would be interested to know
another perspective especially someone
so close to george floyd
as much perspective as we can get on
what happened that day i think the
better but we'll wait and see what
happens
thank you for joining us here on long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you